one thing occurred to me and I was
thinking about this which is for so long
you've been fighting in a big part of
your fighting style and that UFC has
been kicking is it possible that you'll
be out there in the ring not in an
octagon but in the ring and forget and
start kicking Floyd Mayweather could
that possibly happen it's just that part
of your brain takes over and you do the
forbidden and kick him could it happen
well Never Say Never
[Applause]
I've taken this very seriously I've
taken this very seriously I've brought
in a referee a Hall of Fame referee Joe
Cortez has been refereeing each and
every spar and then even back home in
Ireland I had a professional referee
from Ireland based and he was referring
every spar so I've taken it very
seriously to study the real set and
learn the real set I will go in and
dismantle him at his own game
that's what a true mark martial artist
can do they can adapt under any
circumstance Bruce Lee said be like be
like water and when the war when water
enters a cup it becomes the cup that's
the philosophy I'm going into this
contest it doesn't matter what real
cheddar or our stipulations they try and
put on me I can adapt and overcome to
any situation and that's what I will do
on August 26th very confident men and
did you have you studied Floyd's defense
because people have said it's next to
impossible to get a punch in at the man
do you think you've found something that
other fighters have not found a way to
get in and get at Floyd I think I think
the styles of opponents that Floyd has
faced have moved in a certain way
they're they're the boxing game is
almost set in its way I feel that their
feet are flat
they have no spring in and out compared
that really mixed martial artists they
can bounce in and out at a fast tempo so
I believe I will paint pictures in there
that he has never seen before or the
boxing community have never seen before
and that will cause him big trouble fact
that I didn't with the precision and the
punching power it only takes me one shot
I have ko'd men inside three seconds I
won the UFC featherweight title in 13
seconds so factor all those things close
with the punching power on the precision
it's over for Floyd and that's it okay
[Applause]
you